the FDA is making a major change in the
way it evaluates addiction treatment
drugs this could create more options for
addicts the FDA will now look at whether
potential treatments can reduce overdose
rates or the transmission of infectious
diseases instead of only focusing on
whether it cuts opioid use now this is
the latest effort to fight the drug
abuse epidemic that killed nearly 64
thousand people in 2016 in the new book
dope sick it's called dealers doctors
and the drug company that addicted
America author Beth Macey track C opioid
epidemic from its early days in rural
America to the nationwide crisis that it
is today she joins us at the table to
discuss
good to see you Beth Macey thanks for
having you've got so much interesting
information in this in this in this book
about how serious this is we hear all
the numbers but you started working on
it six years ago and when you first
started people were like don't use my
name I don't want to talk about it and
now people are saying look I want my
story to be told because the numbers are
astounding right we have the equivalent
of a 911 happening every three weeks
basically 145 Americans dead from opioid
overdose and you're right the stigma is
still such that a lot of people don't
want to talk about it but almost it's
impossible to ignore you I pick up my
local newspaper and there's a young
person almost every but you tell the
story you're at a gravesite and a mother
says to you I just want to know what did
she say to you that she wanted you to
find out about her said I don't
understand why my burly handsome barely
old enough to grow a beard on his chin
ended up dead on someone else's bathroom
floor and she said something else that I
heard a lot which is I thought it was
just pills and it had progressed to
heroin unbeknownst to her and he never
missed a day of work and so many people
looking for the culprit behind this you
refer to Purdue Pharma as the drug
company that addicted America now Purdue
told us that they've quote led industry
efforts to help address prescription
opioid abuse adding that suggesting
activities that led that last occurred
more than 16 years ago for which the
company accepted responsibility help
contribute to today's complex and
multifaceted opioid crisis is deeply
flawed
what role did this company play in this
opioid crisis in the country in 1996
oxycontin was introduced and the FDA
allowed the company to make the squishy
claim that it was because of his time
release mechanism it was believed to
abuse to lessen the risk of overdose in
addiction and produce in its
pharmaceutical reps out to doctors who
were already prescribing percocet and
immediate release and they said that
oxycontin was safer because this 12 hour
time release mechanism and they plied
them with gifts they paid thousands of
doctors to become speakers and this
squishy claimed that it was reduced to
that it was believed to reduce the risk
of addiction was then trumpeted and
became I say in the book that it became
like a game of telephone gone terribly
awry old data was trotted out the
federal government proved they agreed in
2007 that they had criminally Mis
variant and the drug and in those early
years they were always blaming the
overdose deaths the skyrocketing crime
especially in these distressed rural
areas on on the people that were
misusing their drugs they they never
took responsibility I want to ask you
this is what Purdue Pharma told us the
bulk of opioid prescriptions are not and
have never been for oxycontin which
represents less than two percent of
current opioid prescriptions the company
says today is increase of fatal opioid
overdoses are due to heroin and illicit
fentanyl you're wearing a locket tell me
about that yeah relates to what they
said I'll show you a picture of a young
woman who I followed for two and a half
years this is Tess Henry on the Left she
was a waitress when I met her she was
young mother she had been over
prescribed to opioids at an urgent care
center for simple case of bronchitis 30
days and at the end of the 30 days she
realized she was hooked and then she
sought out street drugs because she
wanted not to be doped sick and that's
basically withdrawal she wanted not to
have diarrhea
you know fevers nausea they all say it's
like the worst food that part of the
problem is your prescription and
dopesick refers many of these people are
trying to get high they're just trying
to prevent getting sick from the drugs
it's very controversial and complicated
issue very hearing on tests yes name
with that necklace right I think thank
you thank you for joining us